Guys, I Guys, I don't like saying this.
I feel uncomfortable making THIS VIDEO.
I WANTED ALL of this TO GO AWAY. I JUST
SAID, "NO, I'm not going to [__] you,
bro. Get out of here." I just tried to
ignore the kid for 5 years. Here we are
5 years later. He won't stop talking
about me. Look, I'm feeling sick even
though like just like the hell. Where is
this coming from?
I want to invite you to add something
powerful to your Sadaqah Jariyah list.
We're on a mission
>> to teach tens of thousands of people
around the world
>> how to pray salah properly.
>> Just imagine this. You help someone
learn wudu, how to pray. How to recite
Surah Al-Fatiha. Every Fajr, Zuhr, Asr,
>> Maghrib,
>> Isha, Tahajjud,
>> Tarawih. Every prayer for the rest of
their lives, you share in the rewards.
When they teach their children, and
their children's children, the reward
continues for you. For just £100, you
can help teach 20 to 60 people
>> like me learn salah. Donate today and
earn rewards that never stop.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh, brothers and sisters and dear
friends. So,
I did say I wouldn't want to speak about
Andrew Tate anymore, but
I can't really help myself. Why? Uh
because he's now not only calling
accusing um Sneako of being a
homosexual, he's also doxing his family
members, especially his mother. And
that's a very cowardly behavior. And a
video was sent to me of uh brother
Muhammad Ali, may Allah bless him and
preserve him, doing fantastic work in
the Dawah. Um
calling him a coward. And I'll be honest
with you, we know brother Muhammad Ali,
yes? Okay. He's a very calm, collected
guy, you know, he controls his anger,
etc. When I heard him calling Sneako a
coward, I mean a
uh
as you say a coward, I was like, "Yo, if
if Muhammad Ali, Muslim Lantern, is
calling you a coward, brother, you have
to be a coward. Okay, let's be honest,
yeah? Okay. Um so, subhanallah, you
know, let's let's let's let's just watch
this inshallah for ourselves." If I got
a girl's number on Fresh and Fit, he
tried to do the same thing. Every single
thing I did, he copied verbatim. He
tried to be me, literally be me. He was
obsessed with me. And I thought he just
wanted to be famous, and that turned out
to be a homosexual obsession. He came to
Romania with two people who I respect
very much, Myron and Fresh, great guys.
They managed to convince me to allow him
to come. He came there and started
acting really fruity and really weird.
He started telling me that he had this
cuck uh thing that was exposed. He had
this big cuck scandal. And he asked me
what I think about cucking and if it's
normal to explore your sexuality and if
I've ever tried it, and I said, "Look,
I'm older than you, bro, and I've never
tried that. I don't think that's
normal." And then he starts saying,
"Isn't it normal just to try new things?
Don't you think it's normal to be
curious? How do you know if you're
really gay or not unless you've tried
being gay?" And then I realized he was
coming on to me. And when I realized he
was coming on to me, I thought the best
thing I can do is just not talk to him
anymore cuz I don't like this Gossip
Girl stuff. I don't want to be a drama
merchant like he is. My brand isn't
sitting online and constantly insulting
other people like his is. So, I thought,
"Let me just cut him off. He's obsessed
with me. He's a bit weird. I don't want
to ruin the guy's career. Let me just go
his own separate way." Since then, he
has mentioned me every single day in
every single stream he does. Andrew Tate
wore gambling t-shirt. Andrew Tate drove
a car. Andrew Tate drank coffee. Andrew
Tate this. Andrew Tate that. He is
obsessed with me. And if you see the way
he talks about me, you can see in his
eyes. It's not because he is morally
superior. It's not because he just wants
clicks. It's a homosexual rage, which is
suppressed. Guys, I Guys, I don't like
saying this. I feel uncomfortable making
this video. I WANTED ALL OF THIS TO GO
AWAY. I JUST SAID, "NO, I'm not going to
[__] you, bro. Get out of here." I just
tried to ignore the kid for 5 years.
Here we are 5 years later. He won't stop
talking about me. And if you watch him
do it, guys, watch him do it and look in
his eyes while he does it. It is a
suppressed homosexual rage. He is
enraged. Now he's Muslim larping. He's
Islam larping. Constantly larping about
Islam while being gay in private and
taking drugs in private as opposed to
me, who keeps my faith private and my
internet internet. He keeps his faith on
the internet, and in his private life is
completely haram. So, we can discuss
which one of us is a real Muslim if we
want to have that conversation. So,
guys, you saw that for yourselves,
subhanallah. Look, and let me let me
honest with you guys. You know what it
reminded me of? It reminded me of a
couple of months ago where I was calling
out nifaqis, these radical feminists who
hate men, okay, because of their
decision-making factors of choosing
spouses uh for that matter, and coming
at me.
"You're in love with me. You're in love
with me. You love us. You love me. You
love me." You know, he's going to do
that. It was because they couldn't deal
with the arguments of the truth that I'm
speaking, which is stop calling for
people to get divorced. This is This is
not right. This is wrong. Then what did
they do? They had to label me something,
which is what? So, people can say, "Ah,
you're doing this cuz you're in love
with them."
Okay. So, you can see when people are
cornered and they have nothing to say,
what do they do? Ad hominems.
And Andrew Tate, with all due respect,
you're doing exactly the same. Why would
you, bro, out of anything accuse Sneako
of being homosexual? And not only that,
wanting to sleep with you. Look, I'm
feeling sick even though like just like
the hell.
Where is this coming from?
Like where is this coming from? Because
you know very well he's making sense.
I'm not saying Sneako's always right cuz
I've also defended you when Sneako I
think accused you of something that he
shouldn't. So, I'm not no Sneako just
cuz I chill with him. I don't have no
loyalty to Sneako. I'll say it to He's
going to probably watch this. I have no
loyalty to Sneako. I am Wana, Muhammad
Hijab, myself, my dad, my granddad, my
children, nobody. Our line is messenger.
So, I've called out Sneako when he was
wrong. However,
why would you I find it very I'll be
honest, I would never ever I've never
had that experience ever. But oh, this
guy who wants to be like imagine me
saying, "Oh, there's this guy and he
would try to sleep
I can't even repeat it. I can't." I find
it very weird that fact of everything
you accuse him of homosexuality and that
he tried to move to you.
That's so weird, bro. That's so bizarre.
It's so bizarre, yeah? If you was not a
Muslim, I would say you're projecting
maybe you're gay and you're saying he
is. I would say if he was not Muslim.
I'm not going to say that because you're
a Muslim, yes? And I'm going to say
that. So, now I'm going to go to a video
of Muslim Lantern and Sneako talking
about this. And Muslim I I I'll be
honest, like I said before, I was
surprised that Muhammad Ali, Muslim
Lantern, came out and called you out cuz
he Muslim Lantern is a very calm guy,
yes? And him coming out, bro,
let's watch for ourselves. For me, I'm
not insulting him. I'm saying a fact.
When I used that term, he was a coward,
I know he was a coward. Why? Because he
avoids confrontation with people who can
put him in his place when he lies. He
avoids confrontation with people I mean
I said he avoids confrontation. This is
literally what I said about him because
he was avoiding speaking to Muslims who
would call him out on the lies that he
was repeating. When I called him a
coward, he 100% proved it when he did
what he what he did with your family.
And you know, I met your father, I met
your family. They're very lovely people,
very nice people, man. They don't get
involved in this garbage and nonsense.
What's the family got to do with
anything?
You are the coward the biggest coward on
Earth if you go and attack someone's
mother.
Not even a father. You go and and
speaking about someone's mother. Someone
Yeah, what's this? Wallahi, you shocked
me when you sent me this. Because like
imagine talking about masculinity
and being a man and speaking about
someone someone's mother.
It's
it's insane, man. I swear to God, he is
the biggest coward. Look, people have
been seeing all of these clips of him
walking like a duck when he's trying to
shoot. And
I really didn't understand how does he
post this clip online. How do I just say
he
He said I'm gay
came on to him and
No, he said that I that I wanted He said
that I was like trying to human traffic
him. Like Yeah. Brother, brother, look.
Yani, okay.
You sit down on a keyboard, brother.
Brother, you sit down on a keyboard
because he's calling your past, and this
is his past, which is public.
Uh which obviously there's nothing gay
in your past anyways, but he called
other things in your past, right? But
what his what is his past like? He sat
down on a keyboard.
We have women uh that are displaying
their body,
and he tried to arouse men.
He was writing sentences
to get guys' private parts to stand up.
You know, I'm trying to be very clear.
I don't use vulgar language vulgar
language over here. So, I'm going to I'm
going to say I'm going to try to be as
as reserved as possible. Uh may Allah
keep us, you know,
uh honest in Ramadan. But the thing is
this, look.
He was doing this sitting on a keyboard
doing this.
If you want to attack someone,
I think that's the the for you number
one on the list is the thing you cannot
use.
You lost that card, you know? This card
of calling someone else gay, the minute
you admitted that you're proud of this.
Here's the difference. There are things
people attack you with your past when
you clearly claimed you you were you
were young. You you regretted this. It
wasn't the right thing. You took it
back. Him, what did he say?
And I don't want to bring this stuff up
because you're
you're supposed to be forgiven of your
sins. I'm bringing it up. I'm bringing
it up. I'm bringing it up. I'm bringing
it up. I'm not No, no, no, there's a
difference. I'll tell you something.
You When someone attacks another
believer,
I'm sorry, I just find it so funny that
Sneako's alive with Muslim Lantern and
he's giving you that ba whatever it
means. I forget. But I'm being honest,
guys.
I know brother Muhammad Ali.
We don't agree on everything when it
comes to Islamic rulings, etc., yeah? We
have our differences. However, beautiful
brother, lovely Dawah. May Allah bless
his Dawah. Okay, alhamdulillah. We're
happy to have a brother like him who's
doing Dawah.
I've never seen Muhammad Ali like this.
I'll be honest with you. We had a
discussion with him on different topics,
etc. We had a little back and forth,
etc. as brothers. But I've never seen
Muhammad Ali like that, bro.
Bro, you have to really go under his
skin for him to call you out like that,
bro, in Ramadan. So, and the truth is
truth. I didn't even know that he was
texting men about this. That that's mad.
That's mad. I'm so sorry. That's That's
crazy. And there's nothing else to be
said, guys. I I'm not going to say
nothing else. It's Ramadan. May Allah
subhana wa ta'ala protect us. But you
know what? I'm so sorry, man. Again,
before, Sneako has proven himself like,
you know, as a Muslim who genuinely
believes. Andrew Tate he says, "Oh, his
faith is different etc. I don't think so
brother. All I'm going to say is
May Allah bless and preserve you guys.
Till next time as-salamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh. Brothers and
sisters, do not forget to support our
cause. We're looking for just 100 people
to give 100 pounds. That will help teach
20 to 60 people to learn how to do wudu,
to learn how to pray salah, to learn
surah fatiha, surah ikhlas. Brothers and
sisters, your donations, if you go to
the link it goes to five four five key
areas that teach people how to pray
salah brothers and sisters. Donate now
and it is a sadaqah jariyah that if one
person learns how to do ablution, how to
pray salah, learn surah fatiha for the
rest of their life, you get every single
reward. Go to the link and donate now.
Goodbye. This is the new sadaqah jariyah
in town. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
us in the Quran a man pleading with
Allah to send him back so he could give
sadaqah. Why sadaqah? Because he knows
the weight of sadaqah. Just 100 pounds.
You can help teach 20 to 60 people to
learn how to perform salah, recite surah
fatiha, and make wudu. Click the link
and donate now.